the jurogan experience well when you
make films like elysium you know these
dystopian films about potential futures
it's got to have like sort of sparked
these thoughts in your mind like the how
many of these possibilities could we
encounter in our lifetime
well elysium was
i mean elysium and district 9 are both
kind of cut from the same cloth in the
sense that i do think a lot of that had
to do with growing up in south africa
and just being affected by i'm very
naturally interested in
how society seemed to stratify and how
wealth inequality you know again this is
biological programming right like i
think i think that people hang on to
resources that they have
as much as they can and so you end up
with you end up with with billionaires
um because it's it's an understandable
thing right it makes total sense you're
just hoarding food in your cave to look
through the winter you know right right
and keep your family safe
so but but elysium really
if if district 9 was the was the sort of
racial part of growing up in south
africa and just
being very aware of the environment that
i was in then elysium is the kind of
wealth discrepancy part of it you know
where south africa and brazil and india
would be
would be in first place when it comes to
that
and you just see very you see imagery
that's extremely striking
um
in that country that leaves an indelible
mark on you i think actually you know
the inspiration for elysium entire in
the the the whole thing actually for me
was
i was shooting commercials in um it was
i was it was 2005 and i was i was i had
started directing commercials and i was
doing a commercial for nike and i was in
uh san diego and the line producer that
i was working with really wanted to go
to tijuana and and i was like sick i
didn't want to go and he's like we gotta
get in the car and we gotta go to
tijuana like now we gotta go down there
and get get a beer or something and i
was like i really don't want to do this
and he's like let's just go it'll be
fine
so i i went we went through the the
border into mexico as the sun was going
down and
we got there and got onto you know we
were on some street corner and i we
bought beers and then we were walking
around in tijuana with the beers and
these federalists saw us doing it
and we got arrested like kind of
relatively violently where we were you
know it was a shakedown for money
obviously but it was like we we are
cuffed and thrown in the back of a
police car and then they started driving
out of tijuana
in the darkness
and um
and the producer that i was with kept
putting like hundred dollar bills
through the graded thing to the to the
front seats and then once there was
enough money that had gone through they
just kind of opened the doors and let us
out
and we had to walk back to where the car
was and how far was the walk i don't
remember how long we were walking for it
was it felt long it felt like
40 or like an hour maybe 40 minutes
somewhere in there
but the thing that was crazy about it
was
was i could see
u.s blackhawks flying the border with
like lights on them and and floodlights
on the far on the u.s side
and we were walking through
basically favelas with dogs barking and
like they had dropped us in places that
like tourists from the us would never go
so we were walking in basically what
felt like a south african shanty town in
mexico
uh with feral animals and just like this
but to see
this country that you know is was was
this the sort of global hyperpower that
everyone from mexico was moving into
um
was trying to get into uh was
incredibly striking like it was just
crazy i mean it is crazy if you think
about that that level of poverty up
against the us border and then
and i think elysium really was
was
the sort of subconscious part of it was
south africa but the conscious part was
that i at in that moment i was like i
really want to find a way to turn
that experience into
into visuals
that represent
these two worlds that live on one
another's doorstep like this so you were
as you were walking by you could see the
planes that were flying over the u.s
side not the planes it was border patrol
there were black hawks there were oh
helicopters they were yeah they were
flying the border
and um and just flood lights there were
floodlights like along the along the
fence along the perimeter like i guess
they driven us kind of like you know
east of of where we were
it was weird it was it was it was very
impactful though like it had a huge
effect on me
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify